Do you have any ideas on how to sleep through the night? Well, it depends on
what the issue is. So if you can't fall asleep at night, then typically you think of taking
some things that will call me your brain and
stimulate melatonin or you take melatonin. There's different
nutritional supplements out there that are
that are calming to your brain and you know, and will help you relax and fall asleep.
But if your problem is I wake up in the middle of the night and then I can't go back to sleep.
Well, are you waking up for a purpose? Are you waking up to go to the bathroom?
Or are you waking up because of pain? Whether you want to address those things?
Or I wake up to go to the bathroom, but I used to be able to get back to sleep and I can't get back
to sleep again. Then you have to think of cortisol issues and dealing with cortisol.
Sometimes eating a protein before bed can be helpful for that. So eating a little piece of chicken
before you go to bed can be helpful with that. Because you could get a cortisol drop at the
middle of the night and then you can't get back to sleep unless you get up and walk around because
your brain is basically starving for glucose and you burned all your glycogen stores.
Or your cortisol level is low because you're stressed out and you don't break down the glycogen
stores because you need cortisol to break down the glycogen stores and you're liver to produce glucose
at night to keep your brain alive. So you need a level of glucose at night to keep your brain alive.
So one way you could test that if you really wanted to dig into it is you could test your glucose
level and sleep at night. You could test your glucose level. Sometimes a person, if that's the issue,
sometimes a person will show hypoglycemic in the middle of the night. Then eating something will help
them fall asleep because they have that circulated glucose. So there's different reasons for that.
If a person's not sleeping through the night, like we talked about the other question,
because they have pain, then you start thinking of using like a THC type product that could help them
with the pain and help calm their brain and help them stay asleep. So there's so different,
you want to do like anything you're trying to get to the reason why and fix that. So if the problem
not sleeping through the day is because of pain, then I would think of and if you're already
you know why you have the pain, then I would think of using like a THC product or something like that.
You can't fall asleep, but use something like an insomnetol or some other product with melatonin
and other brain call me things. If you wake up at night, it's not because of pain. You can't fall
back asleep. It could be a cortisol issue. So then you address that. So it depends on what the cause is.